il ya ceux qui aiment les vacances
traditionnelles à devenir professionnel
il ya ceux qui cherchent autre chose
parmi ces derniers jean pierre qui tarde
qui emmenait une équipe de 24 heures sur
la lune d'abord calèche et ensuite en
bateau il s'est même arrangé pour me
voir de la bourgogne que l'eau un cheval
un bateau un cause celui du quercy un
canal en somme de vraies vacances
c'est avec l'un d'entre eux que nous
sommes partis en calèche à la découverte
du lot
l'un des rares départements en france où
la nature se sont encore chez elle
non
nous
une formule originale adaptée au
tourisme champêtre est ouverte à tous ce
qu'ils peuvent mais surtout qui veulent
oublier quelques heures la vie et les
problèmes de la cité
plusieurs itinéraires nous était
proposée qui tous nous ont permis
d'apprécier la rue de beauté du causse
et celle plus verdoyantes des vallées du
lot et du sénat
quel que soit notre route nous n'étions
jamais perdue car les sabots de notre
guide connaissait tous les cailloux du
chemin et le soir ils nous conduisait à
proximité d'un relais équestre où l'on
nous donnait gîte et couvert à nous de
ne pas l'oublier en lui trouvant un prêt
et en lui donnant lavoine et le sud
la calèche ou le carré tout est en
principe prévu pour 4 personnes et leurs
bagages soit 300 kg mais il n'est pas
interdit de remplacer les valises par un
matériel de camping léger l'intérêt de
cette formule étant d'offrir
simultanément soit des vacances
familiales soit des vacances plus
sportive
dans ces conditions le seul problème qui
se pose aux voyageurs et la durée de son
séjour
nous lui conseilleront quand même de
compter deux à trois jours pour se
familiariser avec la conduite du chemin
alors en regardant ces images comment
résister au charme de ce mode de
transport
il est évident qu'après avoir parcouru
une lotte en calèche
on a beaucoup de mal à se retrouver dans
un véhicule à moteur sur des routes où
les chevaux ont disparu depuis fort
monde
autre formule autre plaisir une certaine
façon de vivre ses vacances sur les
rivières de bourgault
90 km de voies navigables entre le doubs
la cei la saône et le canal du sang
m
sans aucune contrainte nous avons
partagé la vie des mariniers car aucun
permis n'est exigé pour conduire ces
maisons flottent
quatre croisières nous était proposé
mais comme on choisit alors nous avons
consulté un petit guide où étaient
réunis les richesses historiques et
gastronomiques de chaque partie mais
tous ces parcours ont un point commun
ils ne peuvent souffrir la précipitation
et en fin de compte qui voudrait aller
plus vite que le courant alors même que
sur les berges les pêcheurs à la ligne
les éclusiers les invite dans leur
domaine
commandant de ce navire vous respecterez
donc sans mal le 6 km vitesse maximale
autorisée sur les voies d'eau navigable
pour ce genre d'embarcation reste la vie
à bord regardez vous avez le confort
d'une caravane quatre lits plus une
couchette d'appoint salle d'eau et
cuisine entièrement équipée une petite
carte vous donnera également les points
de ravitaillement en eau vivres et
essence ainsi que les adresses des
médecins et des pharmaciens
calèche dans le lot maison faute en
bourgogne deux formules de solutions qui
séduiront les amoureux de la nature de
façon d'être pour ceux qui veulent
encore faire de leurs vacances
havre de paix et de rose